foreign
[Music]
Denzel Washington has certainly played
some badasses in his career and even
though he shines in demanding character
traumas as well he's still always up for
some decent popcorn entertainment in
2014's The Equalizer and the 2018 sequel
the equalizer 2. he played the
battleheart and X agent who'd rather
just lead a quiet life but still has to
take up Arms Again The Equalizer 3 is
set to follow suit in 2023 and in this
short preview we now take a look at what
we can expect
let's take a look at the story of The
Equalizer franchise the plot is about
the retired government agent Robert
McCall who has a modest job in a Boston
hardware store he leads a secluded and
humble life and likes to spend his
sleepless nights in a diner there he
meets the young forced prostitute Alina
who is made to work for the notorious
Russian gangster slavi after some
incidents McCall who worked for the
defensive intelligence agency decides to
Ransom the young girl with his savings
when this fails he kills sloppy in his
accomplices in the most precise and
impressive way without getting a single
scratch himself afterwards the Russian
mafia tries to investigate the incident
with the help of their specialist Teddy
Ranson the evidence quickly leads to
Robert who is forced to get rid of
Ranson and his comrades in arms once and
for all the second part connect to the
original and here again fans of the
series were treated to many elaborate
action scenes the focus is once again on
Robert McCall who now lives in an
apartment complex and works as a cab
driver behind the middle class guys
however Robert continues to uphold
Justice in the second part as well so
right at the beginning of the film you
can see him taking out countless bad
guys on a train to Istanbul Alina is
replaced by the young miles Whitaker for
whom Robert becomes something like a
mentor he provides miles with meaningful
activities and even rescues him from the
clutches of a gang at the same time
Robert's longtime girlfriend Susan is
mysteriously killed during an
investigation McCall eventually tracks
down the Killer and is then confronted
with the Abduction of his Protege miles
the big showdown between Robert and
villain Dave York finally takes place in
the protagonist's hometown where he once
again manages to take out the bad guys
in the End McCall moves back into his
old house which he lived in with his
wife at the time and Miles succeeds in
getting into college thanks to his
mentor as for the upcoming third part
there is no in-depth information about
the plot yet in line with what the film
series is about the film will once again
present a new case from Robert McCall's
life in which both the protagonist and
the setting will change already in 2018
the year of the release of The Equalizer
2 director Antoine Fuqua hinted that the
main character in the next part would
spend time outside the U.S more
precisely in Europe since last summer it
has also been known where the crew and
actors are heading namely to Sunny Italy
as soon as the southern European country
was announced as the filming location
there was speculation that Robert McCall
would be messing with a notorious
Italian mafia this time around despite
the fact that filming was completed last
month there's still little footage of
the film and thus few clues for part
three based on statements made by the
director it can be assumed the film will
be much more personal and will shed even
more light in the life of the lead
character we are looking forward to more
information
The Equalizer 3 was shot in Rome Naples
Sardinia Sicily as well as in smaller
villages in Italy among other locations
the associated images released last
October show some of the crew involved
in the project including director
Antoine Fuqua and Washington's co-stars
Dakota Fanning and Gaius scotalero both
are among the new cast members in The
Equalizer 3 but is not known precisely
what roles they will play it seems
possible that Fanning will play Robert
McCall's Protege similar to Chloe Grace
Moretz in the first part what sort of
Tricks the battle-ready ex-government
agent will be up to this time can
finally be discovered in movie theaters
starting September 1st 2023
how did you like the two equalizer
movies so far both Keanu Reeves as John
Wick and Liam Neeson in the taken film
series have already shown that aging X
killers are not to be joked about in the
world of film we are eager to find out
how Denzel Washington performs in The
Equalizer 3 and whether we can expect
further installments of the franchise
[Music]
foreign